here we are everybody welcome I am
actually overcome with dread right now
dread dread what's wrong I just realized
that our number today was what 64 64
right I have no numbers I'm violating
one of the commandments standby
ghostrider what I am so excited to get
to all the other things that we have
today right and it slipped my frickin
mind yes it did okay we don't need we
can just come up with him on the fly he
said Joshua he's got to do something
here for the company
yeah maybe once we are going to be
calling phil simms he's already told
Kris not to call that he's too busy
don't matter that we're calling him and
he was doing a commercial for a
Hackensack hospital with Harry Carson I
mean jeez I know some of this phil simms
commercial money me too but it's too bad
my sister's the only one that gets it
she's a she's on full scholarship but
phil simms university but you know what
all things paid $400 handshakes included
it's her salary for planning next year's
draft party if you want to plan a party
at my father's house there's nobody
better to ask
she's your dress since I followed her
own social all I saw was swans and
balloons there's a party at this place
every day I told her Grant heard little
boy Patrick who's a cutie he was one
years old I said man Patrick it's a
shame this is gonna be the best party of
your life and you'll never remember it
candy we have a lot of stuff to get to
in terms of some aging quarterbacks
thinking they can still play yeah we are
gonna have our mascot battle hope you're
ready for that well we're gonna have a
whoa big offseason we have an O bad
offseason and we have some quotes that
I'm excited about but first I want to
get to some of our awesome fans on Sims
Aleph go and kind of the things that
they've sent us that I'd like to
spotlight okay we have an Instagram DM
from deep hot 12 that I really really
enjoy what up D pots do you want to read
it mr. pendrick yeah I was going to pull
it up right now so this one came in
earlier today I came in yesterday
actually was talking to my girlfriend
about Katie Nolan salary
I made the comment that I was in the
wrong profession girlfriend responded
with yeah you should have been those
loud guys you listen to all the time
Levski and scott we're gonna go in
scoffs ki and Scott it's our egos ski
Levski and scott i love when we hear
from our listeners I talk about
listening to us on all that yeah it's
more of the significant others that are
like what the hell you listening to
right it's love skills it's like the one
comment always goes into my brain as the
guy who said he lost the weight and he'd
been eating the rice and beans and his
parents were like it's kind of stupid
you're listening to an athlete it's a
podcast about diet diet yeah no that's
not it wasn't it but either no I'm
saying though that's not what he's
listening to like that was broadcast
right and I mean wouldn't a fleets no
diets pretty good hope you're right you
even think so we honest how much money
is she making New York Post said that
she's getting seven figures from ESPN
she is currently doing like two to three
snapchat stories and then the process of
developing her a digital show wait seven
figures Wow just like Levski and Scott
good for her yeah but wait so snapchat
what was she doing this is incredible
she's doing like a one-minute snapchat
show where people watch like quick
10-second clips or she's like do you see
that homerun by Jean Carlos stand there
like that was lit got you and you're
like see how we connect with young
people yes right yeah it's really good
stuff right ESPN social engagements plan
once again I think so right I like her I
sat next to her at the Red Sox World
Series game once she had no idea who I
was but I was sitting there and we were
watching Red Sox win their first World
Series Wow in Fenway and like over a
hundred years hit it off I mean you know
me that was me I think she thought I was
I don't think she knew what the hell I
was I don't think she had any just some
guy yeah yeah yeah so I didn't know you
guys were best friends besties like we
just I just got this diem from Nathan it
said no I'm not stop no stop I'll make
you a deal I'll play fantasy football if
you start listening the Sims and left go
and the other guy goes deal I'll put it
on at work and this guy damned
Maiki Bush he goes a making deal so I
have people to go to the draft party
well yeah like who is that guy Mikey
Bush make sure he's listening to the
podcast and not bullshitting you but my
favorite tweet that we got you may
remember this guy sound so let's turn up
the volume real quick this is my man
Mario Salazar first pick in the 2008 NFL
Draft Justin Jackson
[Music]
[Music]
so that's Mario Salazar and I was like
this guy's a legend he went up there and
was like la note always in my heart
Sunday he tweeted us right and said I
called the Chargers seventh round pick
on national television and proceeded
this [ __ ] on Dean Spanos sorry Joe for
one day for next year's draft
I want to crash y'all's draft party
always in my heart San Diego Chargers
sins a left go listen yeah your cups and
sizes and fame Mario Salazar he killed
it he's come with a draft party did you
pull the one from big Jordi that I read
before about stand-ins what was that I
got to read that oh yeah we do got to
read that but we got to figure out for
real like we're doing the draft party I
don't think my dad knows what he's
signed up for so this one was big Jordi
3,000 and he said that seems a left go I
proposed each first rounder gets a stand
in a random fan at the party to walk to
the podium and shake big fails hand dibs
on being Nick Bosa standed already
growing out the locks to prepare you
would have been so perfect as Josh Rosen
I could have done this year oh so
instead of since we can't have the
players come up we just have random fan
random fans dressed up as the players
and your dad at the podium like Roger
he's Rogers shaking everybody's hand and
taking pictures as they come up I think
that's actually I do too actually I
think it's amazing cuz Phil that's a
good selling point to convince Phil yeah
we're gonna make you the Commissioner
guy who wears like a thing that says I'm
Nick Bose has the same hairstyle as
Roger
anyways perfect I'll work I love that
alright so I want to talk about some of
the things that we were talking about on
Monday first is Big Ben the [ __ ] hmm
it's really interesting that so much of
the online conversation in reaction to
our opinion was no one can get over how
much people dislike Big Ben yeah and a
lot of people called me out and said why
are you defending this guy all last year
you were tired of it and all that
I guess my thing is I've accepted that
Big Ben is kind of a low life kind of
person stemming from the accusations
early on it's kind of hard to move past
the night but then also like he's been
rude to everybody I've gone over the
martavis bryant the coaching staff he
kind of treats everyone with disrespect
to the point where I look at him like
Kobe he's just kind of that guy guy and
we're not gonna change him right so I
read these stories about people saying
it's time for you to become a gentleman
I'm just gonna embrace him for who he is
that's right that's it but now we want
to get him motivated but it's not just
us TJ McConnell from my Philadelphia
76ers was on the DP show and said
McConnell who's from Pittsburgh was a
Steelers fan growing up until he had an
unpleasant experience with Big Ben quote
I met Ben a while ago when I was little
it wasn't too good of an interaction I
respect him of as a player he wasn't the
nicest guy
he stopped rooting for the Steelers
after that and became a Bengals fan yeah
this is the wake of Big Ben right and I
have a to hate Kobe and then later on in
life I appreciate these characters I
appreciate a lot of [ __ ] in sports
that just embrace that and now I'm kind
of turning to support this character
he's interesting yeah it is interesting
I think we all just it's it's not BS
it's just not fake politician talk you
know like like we talked about with
Brady having n the canned answer of all
I pretty the visit I please the threat I
mean it looked like he's sit in the
mirror and was like let me make this
face as I said so that but it's not that
there aren't [ __ ] in sports it's
just that they're willing to put on a
public face
where I was gonna go with this right
look like Chris Paul in front of the
camera is always like hi I'm Chris and
cliff Paul I've been behind everyone's
like he's ruthless Big Ben
I mean I've heard it from teammates I
mean you can't even ask him for an
autograph some days you can't like hey I
got a you know I need to send this ball
for this kid I knew but he won't sign
for everybody all the time it's the kind
of guy he is so this is consistent with
Big Ben he's asking not fans yes
teammates asking him am i liking so or
now because he at least is a consistent
person but like you said he's not my
favorite person but the lack of fakeness
makes me like him more I think I agree
with that
is he a little diva-ish at times
certainly and that annoys me to a degree
but man he is a baller and I think
that's the point I wanted to make is a
lot of good sports figures out there
that we all loved and adored that aren't
the same person that we think they are
in front of the camera when they're
smiling it oh it's so great to see the
postgame reporter yes I'm this person
your questions but I'm gonna leave here
and go do drugs and have sex with girls
and do everything else wrong they treat
everybody like an [ __ ] but back in
front of you with a smile again like I'm
perfect like I that was always my issue
with Dwight Howard yeah it was like he
always was like the shining star and
it's like dude I did nothing wrong just
everybody hates me because I'm so nice
yeah exactly so maybe that's what it is
is like Kobe was the same way to Kobe I
think played the game a little bit more
early on and yeah me and Shaq I didn't
do anything right and then by the end of
his career he's like oh I don't want you
on my team yeah softly and I was like
wow brutal honesty and I just kind of
cherish that yeah I get that Michael
Jordan is people think like people like
Michael Jordan know like nobody hates
didn't like them so again that has
nothing to do with the success of a
player whether you're liked in the
locker room disliked whatever it may be
it's about respect and about being able
to work with the guy and really
performance on the field Trump's all it
just does it doesn't really matter I
mean Warren Sapp yeah there was
definitely half the team of that and I
was there in Tampa that was like man he
is such a pain in the ass such a loud
but he was open with him he was open
with eve is the same guy every day and
the the results on the field smoke from
themselves to where okay what are you
gonna say what are you do
and me um we'll get to sex today you
hear that worin started his own podcast
he asked me on it
you're gonna do it he was supposed to go
on it today I mean they had to do it
we're gonna do it next week but route 99
I heard is being called I don't know
I'm interested to see how it goes I am
Tim Hill he's if he is willing to open
up and really open up we need which is
what he should do because I mean there's
already enough skeletons in his closet
right to where people already have a bad
needs to embrace the skeleton I think he
does too and if he did he has so many
funny stories and so many little hanging
out with Michael Jordan he was sponsored
by Jordan I know some of those stories
I can't tell everybody out there but
they're amazing no there's a lot of
those out there where I would go we have
to get the okay from vendrick if it's
okay to have them all again yeah yeah
we'll talk about it the other thing I
thought was interesting for Monday's
show is when I mentioned Matt Ryan's new
contract you thought of Tom Brady
I thought of Aaron Rodgers yeah and I
think this is what I want to do now when
we have big contracts is the name game
because I went out in the bleacher
report and I said when you heard Matt
Ryan big contract what did you think
good what a number of people sisal julio
jones and i said what do you mean they
go because he got him all that money and
he's not seeing any of this and i'm like
that's a new thing that is a new thing
so for me when a new big contract comes
out books i want to play the name game
right which is who was the first person
that you thought of right when this guy
got the money because for me the way we
talk about contracts did he get paid too
much did he get not paid enough like
Jarvis Landry who's the first guy that
you thought of for me it was Odell or me
too when I thought of Jarvis Landry I
was like managed Jarvis getting that
money that Odell's getting that money
right but I think that's an interesting
way to look at contract is this like you
actually would have thought of Kyle
would there with it we actually had a
lot of people and bleacher report that
what I actually thought of Kyle Shanahan
because he got his money certainly yes
he put the nail in the coffin for Matt
Ryan to go oh no this guy's legit he can
bring you to a Super Bowl yes that
drives up his price I'm with you with
the Russell Wilson thing too that was
one of the yeah I went probably Rogers
Brady and then I thought of Russell
Wilson I said damn Russell Wilson I mean
what does Julio Jones think about Matt
Ryan's
we have that discussion we didn't have
that one on Monday no I don't who Li L
has been paid so he's not going to be
too jealous of that it's just accepted
at the quarterback's yeah it's gonna be
the same issue though it's not gonna be
an issue there because he performs
always but you know the quarterback has
always looked at a little bit by a lot
of the guys on the team out of the
corner of the Ryder just go man why is
he's worth double me or triple me mine
take his Lance and run 70 more yards
with him Julio's never played for
another quarterback other than Matt Ryan
yes when a guy goes and he sees other
quarterbacks performed he's seen Aaron
Rodgers perform he's seen Matt Stafford
he's seen Tom Brady if he's never played
with another quarterback though is he
more forgiving is he not looking outside
because this is the only guy he's has
yes you're spot-on yeah I would think
you know a little bit like when we heard
from Marty be like Marty B was talking
about Rodgers he was comparing it to
Brady a little bit yeah you're
definitely gonna do that and be like oh
man I mean when when blah blah blah I
used to throw me the ball I'd come out
of the break and it'd be right there but
if you've never played for him you don't
know you don't know what's out there
know you he's like getting married at 20
yeah I'm sure he looks at like your life
every now era let's just say Big Ben and
Julio goes am I wish Matt could throw
the deep ball like Big Ben I mean I'm
sure he that thought goes through his
head he's seen it enough to know he's
better than my guy at throwing that ball
but ya know there's gonna be a common
respect there just saying there's always
gonna be a bond between Julio Matt Ryan
cuz what it was was not consecutive
drafts but it was like it was Matt Ryan
and what oh six ro seven and then Julio
and oh nine I believe it was oh nine I
think so same drafted AJ Green yeah they
traded all those traffic's up with the
Browns right it was pretty sure it was
oh nine cuz I watched Alabama play Texas
the national championship game that year
on the field and I remember Julio Jones
coming on the field for pregame I was
like wow so this is why this kid's gonna
be the top five pick he's amazing he was
amazing looking it's a similar
conversation to what you guys have
always said about Aaron Rodgers what if
he was handed Josh McDaniels playbook
and he got to experience that sure first
sure yes there's a lot of things you can
go that way Matt Ryan again for me
certainly one of the better quarterbacks
in football is Matt Ryan ever gonna go
down as like an all-time great to me
definitely not
I think he's going to go down he's
probably gonna end up in the Hall of
Fame I don't even know anymore I give up
with that conversation
he's another felt legend to me though
he's not an NFL Hall of Famer I will say
that right now unless he ends up winning
like two Super Bowls you're down the
stretch why is he enough a legend well
he's been pretty awesome I mean he's had
some big-time moments games whatever
else and maybe maybe not a legend all
those biggest moments I guess I guess
you're right this biggest moments
probably the Super Bowl of loss 28 to 3
i I'm not trying to be rude no no I know
he - he went to the NFC Championship
game is rookie year right wasn't it or
as a second of the second year I believe
second year yeah but I don't I don't
have these these Matt Ryan plays that
just pop out in my head he is a he is a
system quarterback then again I will say
this one more time he had a long stretch
of a lot of doubt for like four or five
years he's never been really successful
in the playoffs I think for the like the
thing I you know I would say is he can't
make plays with his physical ability by
himself all the time right when he has a
system and a guy like Kyle could be
surgical yeah right but when the system
wasn't good and Julio's out can he carry
this team physically no I questioned
that he's done that last year I thought
was one of his best years of actually
just making plays with his physical
greatness but I think the other thing
people forget about Matt Ryan that
started his career and I know I've said
it to you before left go is they drafted
him at what the number three pick and
that team was good see people forget
they think all the way drafted number
three they must've been horrible he
saved them no they were a good football
team they got a high pick because Bobby
Petrino and Michael Vick had the dog
situation the year of the season and the
whole season collapse so they ended up
being the number three pick in the draft
when they were team they were probably
one of the top 12 teams in the league
and I'm happy to self scout and proven
wrong and I know that we have Falcons
fans that listen right if you want to
send me the moments I'll correct it on
Monday and I know he's had big wins you
know the beat the Packers to go in but
it's like and I know we give a lot of
credit to Kyle Shanahan for that offense
I just don't really remember a ton of
Matt Ryan play really you're right when
you said that I think that's a good way
to put it but and the home playoff
losses I mean he was up 17 nothing in
the NFC Championship game against the
49ers you know Aaron Rodgers came there
and Oh nine and went on fire remember
that game I mean they go against the
Rams in this last playoffs like
the defense have a defense of touch to
hell they Rams fumbled of is the fumbled
punt remember right and it was to
fumbled putts right that's what set the
game Matt Ryan was really good yeah I
just I think Matt Ryan's in the Hall of
good all of good I don't I don't see it
I know these numbers are gonna be great
but that's an era thing that people need
to figure out better him or Eli Manning
I would take you lamenting crazy no it's
not crazy at all it's it I'm actually
thinking about this in my house right
now obviously but in terms of like their
curry right you're taking Eli I think
they're very similar in the pocket
Matt's actually starting to run more now
than you ever have but in terms of just
like throwing the ball like Eli came up
bigger and bigger moments yep yeah I
think that's your right moments Eli is
multiple moments multiple moment right
yeah and then you see this Mark Ingram
suspended four games does he when he's
had a number of reasons not gonna go
into it he's not getting cleared and I'm
sorry the this is the list of guys that
have been suspended for games
vantes Burfict Mark Ingram Thomas Davis
Cora lijek Vidal Alexander and Mark
Sanchez one more time just go to the
weight room and drink a damn protein
shake okay that's all there is to do it
nothing else there's no magic pill
that's gonna give you an extra bicep or
take off ten ten a tenth and you're 40 I
don't get it and you know me I'm gonna
be critical until proven otherwise I
don't care
well you cheat you cheat you're a
cheater I know I can't like say oh well
this one the case is kind of no first of
all but his lawyer said you read that
comment yet we need to find that because
they kind of contradict themselves a
little bit already I mean they're saying
it's what was their thing they basically
said that it was not steroids it's it's
a I'm pulling it up too they the glare
Minister a man I'm gonna read it - I got
it right here so he tested positive for
a substance that was not a
performance-enhancing subsys nor an
illegal substance but a substance in
fact permissible with proper use
exemption with the NFL he has vigorously
challenged the test results through the
arbitration of the process so why did
you challenge the test results if you've
already on the some medication that
wasn't cleared why are you challenging
it that that doesn't make sense right
right away
from from step one the lawyer talks out
of both sides of his mouth but then they
go on to say the let's see the first
part of the defense okay the second part
has vigorously challenge to test results
well yeah that's what I mean that
doesn't make sense so I guess that was
my point but we just seemed Shady and
until they release exactly what it is he
cheated that's the way there is no so
when you hear that who's the first
person you thought of Alden chimera do
you think alvin kamara can be the
feature back definitely yeah I'm worried
mainly because I go back to the Falcons
game where he got hurt yeah and it was
kind of like not that big of a hit shot
to the head maybe I'm a little bit worn
down from last season when we lost so
many stars like last season was insane
yeah Rogers and Odell and watt and
everybody that I'm I'm excited for
Kamara to get more carries yeah but at
the same point you don't want it to hurt
this I don't know people chances and all
that yeah I don't but I also don't know
if he's built to take the 20 to 25
touches like I know that when you see 15
touches from him last year a game and
how explosive he was you go we need to
get this guy more yeah but I also look
at the other side and go I don't know if
I need him in the middle running up
there into the gut like 10 times no I
like him by the edges I know he can go
up the middle but I don't know if I want
him do it yeah it's gonna be a lot of
wear Alvin for a long time right I know
and you're right that's what they are in
danger of but wearing him out those
first four games the good thing is they
have an easy schedule you know the other
thing I thought of I thought about
Kamara you know the mayor way where my
mind went though it's also the reason he
probably took performance-enhancing
drugs cuz he's a damn Alvin Camaro's
here it's gonna come change my job my
job man I got to get better I got to be
better and what a good mic remark Ingram
had last year a career year so I just
can't I can't let it go man and he said
when we talked to him at the Super Bowl
how much he loved having tomorrow I mean
if he's listened to me I don't mean to
be a dick Mark Ingram yeah but Dale we
love mark I know but he put himself in
this and for now until proven otherwise
yeah you cheated I you know I cannot I
don't steal really is crazy you love
of bad people you love like anti-heroes
the one thing you cannot handle his
cheaters don't know you can't handle
can't do it can't do it captain no
captain do it don't have the power all
right so I got some really great quotes
really good ones we're gonna start off
with Will Blackman posted a picture of a
diamond and a cubic zirconia and he said
dear rookies want to save money by cubic
zirconia earrings you're in the NFL no
one will ever notice you or question do
you know athletes that were buying big
jewelry that wasn't real and stuff from
your days ah yeah I do
you've talked about the jewelry guy in
the Bucs locker yeah but that was real I
got worried though I'm not gonna lie
when I took him to get insured I was
like damn I hope this thing's real I
paid a lot of money for it yeah I really
did a little nervous I was I was
following during James on Instagram and
he show in this briefcase of watches and
he's like yo mama caught this one and it
had a label eighty six dollars he goes
oh man you need to spend money look how
much this shine yes I was like that's
what I'm doing that's true if you've
ever seen the movie dope which I know
you have it now it ends with a scene
where there is a guy with to like Birkin
bags and he goes one of these is real
one of these is fake how do you know
which ones real and it was like a riddle
and it ended with him going the true
answer is the person carrying the bag
determines whether it's real or fake
meaning even if it's real if you don't
look like you should have it they're
gonna think it's fake yeah and if you're
Anna Wintour then you're holding a fake
bag they're gonna assume it's real and
that's thing if you're an NFL player you
could buy fake jewelry and everyone's
gonna go you know his contract yeah you
could get away with it you're right who
cares no I know you're right I thought
that quote was gonna say you're in the
NFL not the NBA or major league baseball
you don't money to buy those things all
right yeah I mean most of these rookies
and guys are coming in the league
they're making hundreds of thousands of
dollars so they can't afford that the
cubic zirconium thing definitely had
some guys I'll say this for me
personally I couldn't do that I could
wear cubic zirconia fake guy couldn't be
like oh this is a Rolex no really it's a
Folex okay I couldn't do it cuz it's
cheating just man up by the shitty
TechnoMarine watch oh so it is and
this is what I wear I'm not wasting
money I don't need to wear a fake
plastic diamond to go
oh I'm fooling people out there with
real diamonds so I couldn't do it I've
all four players saving their money and
not wasting it on jewelry certainly
that's funny yeah pendrick only wears
real diamond do you guys like you like
watches though right yeah watches this
you guys love lunch I do like a lot of
money on them I have one the one the one
I have a big one your wife kind of made
you talked me into it we are at a
charity thing nice watch quote here from
each row each row probably loves watches
cuz he's always on time this is a story
I believe it was from the athletic one
morning in spring training 2017 each row
was in the coach's room looking at his
cell phone text messages each row told
the coaches about one message he had
received from a number he didn't
recognize the guy said he'd gotten each
rows number from Alex Rodriguez and that
he wanted to come meet him and study his
stretching technique what's the guy's
name asked one of the coaches Ichiro
scroll to the end of the text
some guy named Tom Brady who the [ __ ] is
Tom Brady Ichiro it's amazing just so
you know yeah NFL players not that
famous not that vain also each row
doesn't care Ichiro I mean that might
have been the first time he was out from
underneath the rock since he left I mean
it's the stories about each row are
incredible yes he goes to Cooperstown
like six times a year and they know him
and they bring him in a side entrance
and he just goes and reads about history
and it's we've been there it's a cool
experience he visits the graves of dead
an MLB legends Wow he loves the game so
much I mean there are stories about him
that are just his like you talked about
his father a few weeks ago how you
rather is crazy yeah he doesn't have a
relationship with his father and I was
curious who do you think the Ichiro is
of the NFL someone who's like dedicated
so much of their lives to the game and
its kind of separated from society and
that when he leaves really can't leave
the game first thing that came to my
mind was Payton yeah Payton is certainly
one of those guys obsessed with with
history and his play
in it yes he's also the Payton's too
he's too obsessed with his apparently
exactly it's not as pure Ichiro strut
like I thought about like a Larry
Fitzgerald that was the first thing that
went to my head no again I think he's
pretty aware of what's going on in the
world but he does fit that mold of that
guy that's just like nope I take seven
steps and I cut off the left foot and
then I put my hands up in this position
when the ball hits their cousins has a
little bit of ginger right Kirk also
sees the big picture and he's seeing it
as like I am sitting myself up for a
beam and then I will have an a Roth IRA
and I will set aside money for my
children it's almost like unimaginable
its robotic to be in this country in a
sports locker room and not know like you
can't tell me in September and October
that these hasn't been in a major league
locker room that doesn't have an NFL
game on on a Sunday when they're playing
and the guys are sitting there watching
Tom Brady yeah yeah just it's amazing to
me that's amazing even if you're not a
sports fan you know who Tom Brady is
because he's crossed he's transcended
sports hey guys I went to the Met Gala
the other night and you see that's three
people everybody bagging on let's get to
it I'm gonna stop going quotes we'll go
back to it since we're here it's the
return of a segment that you all know
and love it seems raw reactions I show
things to Sims for the first time we get
his reaction apparently he's doing this
so let's go to Tom Brady and Gisele yeah
rocking this suit I'm just gonna put it
up here so you can see yeah there you go
if you google Tom Brady Met Gala
everyone's bagging on Tom Brady I think
part of the reason is Gisele put out a
video earlier where she's like he's
intime me so cute.i isn't he's so cute
and she's like he's like okay enough
enough he he just looks like a magician
I mean III didn't think of that
I mean yeah you're probably right that's
part of the bashing of it I mean how
dare he be handsome and good-looking and
well manicured think he looks handsome
or good-looking in that like I found his
hair to be kind of slicked to one side
like for me
tom is at his best when it's like sporty
town and
wearing a hat you know what I mean your
mug boots yeah but he'd looked so
uncomfortable he was right fine I just
think for a guy who it's all about his
appearance he really seemed like he
didn't want to be there at all he just
looked like that like look at his face
in this photo like he just looks like he
doesn't want to be there you know it's
like he should be in the circus like
he's gonna come out on stage I don't
think it was that big evil magician in a
movie like if Harry Potter see that
they're like this is our new Wizard of
teaching tricks and he's like hello
Harry he's extremely handsome I don't
think there's any way around that okay
and the outfits not that bad now listen
it wasn't May 5th and he's wearing a
turtleneck I understand that so that is
a little weird that's what a lot of
people like that's the study Channel and
people are gonna but the theme was what
the Catholic Church right no that was
the thing it was not the Catholic Church
the theme was something like like wow
look it up look it up look it up I mean
why do you think Rihanna dressed like
the [ __ ] Pope Met Gala 2018 theme
according to google it may become
heavenly bodies
fashion and the Catholic imagination
okay so you were kind of close I was I'm
actually right yeah no I heard the
heavenly bodies that's why Katy Perry
came with wings that was hard that was
the dumbest outfit of all okay we have
one more okay but no I mean I just I
don't like that everybody bagged on
that's all I really did there's such a
Brady fellow I thought it was actually a
cool jacket well one guy that they
didn't get on his back and also an NFL
player Cam Newton was at the Met Gala
was he real here's his out he looks good
that is a nice jag blue purple crazy
jacket with big hat and some sunglasses
it's really cool that he was there I'm
glad to see that now I'm gonna get my
camera real quick now show everybody
that this can that's not a good look so
the guy that everyone loved Cam Newton
Sims hates and the one in terms of his
fashion yeah and you like Brady what
didn't you like about this I mean I
don't go with the theme no definitely
didn't go with the theme I like that
you're a purist to the theme Sims is
banging the table every two seconds here
and I'm hearing it in my headphones I
just I'm not for like that look right
there I will say this about camp like
iridescent what is that water sis reach
to water paint where he gets compliments
no matter what he wears yeah
crate his style is crazy jacket big hat
right big smile yes cam smile I think
cam is handsome he's more handsome than
Tom Brady right there both hands how you
really have a crush on Tom that cam has
given a lot of leverage in his style
yeah and I think sometimes it's like
he's dressing crazy it must be cool yeah
but I just like Camelot I do too it's
cool that he's here I'm excited for that
I wore a jacket like that to my bar
mitzva no you didn't I did I was very
surprised to see Cam Newton at the Met
Gala neat I mean the Met Gala is for the
famous and famous exactly and it's cool
that we I mean I'm surprised Odell
wasn't there I know I don't know if he
was invited I know you know what he was
doing he was working out speaking of
Odell it's our last court of the week
John Mara quote it's not the first
contract negotiation we've ever had it
will get done when it's supposed to get
done Oh
what does that make you think it makes
me think Dam Odell please don't play
just don't play until they sign you
until long-term deal go to all the
workouts run on the grass but anything
involved with other players on the field
competing where you have to run route
some people are gonna cover you and
maybe be underneath your feet if you
have to jump and catch a football
what are you laughing at don't do it I
mean this is this is your one chance to
strike gold and get long term security
for you your family the future of your
family everything don't go on the field
well don't worry
well said he's definitely getting a
contract the question is when and Sims
before you give me your answer it's not
just you participating it's not just me
it's not just fender ik we are putting
this out - Sims and luff kogai many
people out there when they have a child
there is a due date
and everyone gets around they guess
when's the baby going to come and that's
what we're doing
Oh Dells our baby when is that contract
coming I have gone online and I have
gone to expect net which is a website
for guessing baby deliveries yes and
I've built our baby Odell Beckham jr.
I'm gonna tweet out the link later and
it says welcome to Chris and Adams baby
game oh my am listed as the father you
are listed as the mother that's a
disgrace well the work husband you're
the work wife how does that be we
already because Rodell you are the
motherly influence in Odell and I am the
father that just left go PR put out the
workout videos I'm gonna tweet out the
link I'll put it on the YouTube as well
that you guys can go out there it's a
little bit weird
I have already put in my date and my
time you also have to guess the weight
and the height of Odell when he's born
no I've already guessed guy he'll be 15
pounds 2 ounces and 21 inches that's a
big baby I have already made my guess I
have made my guess that Odell gets a
contract July 20th at 4 p.m. and when
does training camp start for them can
you tell me that that was a good that's
a good time frame you're in the time
frame really yeah as soon as you said
when wait I was like oh a week before
camp three days before training camp the
first day of training camp it's gonna be
something like that
so the franchise player designations
happen on July 16th that's when they
have to if they can't agree to a long
term deal before that then the franchise
tag deal stays as it well you're gonna
have to look that up Sims would you like
to enter your what do you got for me I
was just gonna ask if I can introduce a
gambling component to this I'll tweet
that out you can vend moment you are
saying I could say everyone venimos me
five bucks and then whoever gets the
date all venmo the money back to him I
think what we do is the person that gets
that closer we're gonna send them some
Sims and luff go so you do that too
yeah we could send swag that's fine
that's less illegal than gambling I'm
just gonna say the second day of
training camp
okay so whatever that is they report
vendrick here I think it's I think it's
July 23rd July 23rd let's see pre-season
training camp official preseason July
mid-july we're gonna make we're gonna
find out what training camp is and simms
the father's guess is gonna be the
second day of trip I'm gonna go third
day because what's gonna happen is the
first day they're gonna report and
everybody's gonna go oh we're so Dell
right then the second day is gonna be
whoa full-fledged Odell's not here
everybody's caught on and they're gonna
be like all right we got to get in the
room and get this deal done we can't I
can't answer these questions about this
guy anymore okay I'm over it I'm a
lawyer so so Sims will enter his guests
yeah and we're just gonna keep track of
it so Sims and left go listeners I'm
gonna send you to expect net when our
baby Odell gets his contract you go on
there pick and pick a time and a date
and whoever gets it wins will see and
and thus win Odell signs Simpson left I
hope you do this for your own real kid
when he comes okay yeah we'll do that
also if anyone has any suggestions on a
web site to use for this prediction pool
other than a baby prediction website
we're open to that too I guess I I think
we should do this also in the future
with other big contracts but Odell has
kind of been our babe he is our baby so
I'm excited for that speaking of Odell
Beckham the allowed to say that 100
rears its ugly head again del Beckham
jr. came in at 77 Oh 77 he was the top
five best players in football the year
before he only missed 12 games but for
some reason JJ Watt who hasn't played in
two years is only ranked a few spots
behind them snacks Harrison was not in
the top 100 and he came out and he was
pissed and he said I will remind every
lie man we play this year while I'm
whipping their ass that they didn't vote
for me blame it on the top 100 so don't
ask me what's your problem man you
should know already
the list comes back y'all hands gonna
shake when you think of me
snacks Harrison what's he get top 100
player I mean he probably is really he
probably is it so I thought about it so
if it's 100 yes that means that there's
an 11 on offense
there's 11 on defense so that's 22 so
it's about five starting units of O line
and D line yeah
now quarterbacks are gonna get married
that's what happens is those sexy
positions get in there that shouldn't
blind the receivers runners slow level
tight ends there we go well he's not
that great to the top of the touchdowns
this year so he'd touchdowns he had
seven catches on the year but 10 of them
work touchdown like Gabe Jackson would
have no chance of making the list no
some of those guys don't you're right
then they deserve to you're exactly
right and repeat you know what I mean
stuff like that none of them know and
like most the guys voting unless they're
playing the D line they're not even know
Andres Pete's one of the best so vine in
football it's just funny to me that this
happens every year yeah and these
players keep getting up side as I worry
did we just hey Damon Ichiro don't even
know who Tom Brady is relax
there's plenty of people who voted a
[ __ ] coolest I love this was this
around when you were playing yeah a
little bit and did this where you like
did this get discussed in the box locker
room I mean some people feel that it's
like it wasn't even everybody in the
locker rooms that got the part is not
everybody know it was like certain guys
who had have just like a list of top 20
players yeah I think it was something
like that and then you put your top 20
players down and somehow they formulated
that would be good to see of all the
defensive linemen that participate did
they just put all offensive linemen
because that's who they're used to going
again well yeah how many quarterbacks
make this list on a yearly basis like
what do you what is the average right
probably a good amount I mean it's like
20 another 32 making the list are you're
interesting you know that would be worth
it too right yeah
we have whoa big year 100 yet now let's
do next week's big offseason we have bad
offseason we still have mascot battle
and we still have some Sims reaction to
get to but let's call Phil in the cell
okay let's see if he picks up if he does
we got a lot of stuff to talk to him
about we do because we got a big mascot
battle but if he doesn't pick up I'm
gonna leave a voicemail okay leave it
big field because what's he do
right now let everybody know he's doing
the Hackensack hospital commercial
Hackensack hospitals a big Hospital
that's one area that's why he's skipping
this I would love to undercut Phil and
be like you like Phil you'll love the
younger version of Phil Chris and he's
cheaper too I hope he's in the middle of
a take oh hello
that would be amazing at the tone please
record your message when you've finished
recording you may hang up or press one
for more options
hey you big [ __ ] you're supposed to be
on with us right now big Phil big time
in us I see you're in here dropping off
comments to Newsday you're not man
enough to come on our podcast listen man
we have a lot of things to iron out for
this draft party
people want to propose at your house and
you're just gonna big-time us for a
hospital hospitals heal people we give
people stuff to live for way to make a
big decision here thanks dad thanks for
being such a great dad to see ya hang up
on this fool ya think so yeah I hope he
calls back he'll do it yeah he's he's
funny I always send them like an
encouraging thing like you know when
we're done or whatever I'm always like
yeah you were funny did a good job
yeah and he's always the same thing like
oh it's easy with you two idiots or that
yeah it's easy to look good with you two
idiots a big film all right so this is
the whoa big offseason Jett CEO hypes
darn old as the franchise Savior
Johnson this is what he does his brother
his brother brother what's his name
Chris Johnson Christian brother Johnson
I think it is uh he said I think people
are gonna look back and they're gonna
realize 20 years from now this is the
moment that the Jeff shifted that into a
new year and after Jeff's
it became a great team this is my
favorite part of the quote I'm not the
GM I'm not the head coach and then goes
on to give evaluations like them but I
can recognize a great football player
and he's so good at playing football
when everything goes wrong with the
pocket collapses when all goes to hell
you can throw across his body
he can throw on his feeder in the wrong
place he could do a lot of things that
are hard to teach I love that he goes I
don't know football but here's my
football analysis of the coat the
quarterback but the front office is
bought in it's a hope they are the
future I mean he is the future I know
we've talked about it they shouldn't
make him the starter as long as they
don't feel like he's totally overwhelmed
by the playbook or anything like that
there's no point in like you know
waiting or delaying the inevitable he's
the guy they're not going to the Super
Bowl this year Josh McCown is this is it
so just go ahead let them get out there
and play yeah don't you like that though
when they when the owners come out and
and tell you so I always go back to like
this and especially the Jets like come
on man you gotta like they need to of
all teams need to follow the what would
New England do know when good wouldn't
do that okay
they wouldn't annoyed somebody that
hasn't done crap for their organization
yet king of their organization before
he's ever stepped on the field and that
to me it's just unnecessary it's
unnecessary even forced and Arnold used
to put the pressure on them after
pressure from Sam guard all those things
it further places Josh McCown as the
lame duck even though we knew his
chameleon yeah and it eliminates
hopefully motivates Teddy Bridgewater's
contention for this job right just let
it play out
yeah just we don't need your sound bites
no they just need to hear themselves I
think they're definitely they not
realize that when the G the owner or the
CEO says this that it's going to become
a thing or do you think they know it's
going to become a thing and they just
want themselves on the record
who know he's just hoping it becomes a
thing and he's really happy that he got
a guy that they wanted in the draft and
he fell to number three and they thought
my best player did he know that his
quote was gonna become news oh gosh I
sure hope so I mean this it happens
every day in New York where someone says
something and then it becomes news it's
it's such a repeated cycle at the yeah I
mean all right uh-oh rough offseason row
kwan smith has a team issued iPad stolen
from his car but Sims you found it
really interesting because according to
the police report is suggested that
Smith left his car unlocked and you were
completely stunned well yes a little
stunned he's back in Georgia you mean
yes was I the guy in the locker room who
was labeled silver spoon guy I don't
know I always locked my car I didn't
trust anybody out there and this is what
you're not realizing yeah when you live
getting the south yes I didn't leave
your doors unlocked I know when I was in
Nebraska people do that in my town and
old Greenwich and I would go to people's
houses and they go you need to use the
driveway yeah just go in there move car
right I have the key it's still in the
ignition yeah what'd you leave your key
in the ignition when I was back in
Louisville yeah and I would go around
dude the amount of times that my friend
my friend Tiffany go to my house don't
front doors unlock yeah your front door
is unlocked like as a New Yorker you go
this is insane like I have two doors
that automatically lock in my lobby and
then you got to get up and then I lock
that door to it it's crazy it crazy and
empty your car outro Quan Smith I mean
old jerseys in there I mean the iPad
you're gonna leave your PlayBook I've
had an unlocked car that is to me where
I would be like stressing I mean that's
where I would been like I'm not going
anywhere in my life until I find this
damn I thought well I wouldn't even
leave it anywhere other than like
underneath my arm like you see me
walking around with my iPad when I'm
watching a film around here let me use
it no I just I'm gonna keep it because
it's not my property and it's my
responsibility and I'm gonna have it
with me wherever I go
I just have these I'm just say I'm just
happy his BMW x5 didn't get taken
and it's like he got everything back
yeah he did no but I I think it's an
interesting thing in America like some
parts of this country everything's
locked yeah other parts it's like we
trust ever yes right how do the teams
protect their playbooks now that it all
exists in an iPad that's not an actual
book that they have to walk around yeah
yeah I mean that like things can't be
sent to other people yeah well like it
can be contorted controlled by the
football team right by their people like
in their technology department yeah II
literally can wipe the thing clean even
from their office no matter where right
like if he said he lost it they probably
were like oh I pad number 437 - while
we're gonna erase what's in there right
whatever it may be and then it's all
gone I could feel like people could just
like a player could easily just hit a
wrong button and send the whole thing
out like see you doing that I'm just
glad there were saving trees for the
better than fire yeah that's the good on
the iPad yeah the reason I'm just Phil
isn't here is I wanted to make news
today yeah Kurt Warner comes out and
says he's a 47 year old quarterback that
wanted to play and I was like we were
gonna get Phil at 62 and he's gonna say
I wanted to play this year but I need to
know what you think about this Kurt
Warner quote was apparently he was on
like a baseball broadcast quote I was
actually ready to go for this coming
season 2018 I actually talked to a coach
and my wife said go for and I think it
would be great Warner said so I actually
talked to a coach about possibly doing
it if they needed someone but then they
went out and signed somebody I don't
think they thought I was serious so I
think we're completely done now now I'm
done
he needs the read he goes the enemy like
badly yes so it's been an interesting
two weeks of Kurt Warner saying how was
I passed up for Monday Night Football
and I can't believe that coach didn't
take me seriously now that cryptic text
message he sent about the Monday Night
Football where he said it had nothing to
do remember he said he said like why are
people that are getting this the people
that are deserved it should be qualified
and then he said oh no I was just
talking about Darr world in general like
he wouldn't man up to say like no I was
actually drew mourners interesting
because the first like eight years of
his career all you heard about was the
Iowa Stampeders and the bagging
groceries and isn't this story amazing
yeah and now that you see him being like
I
I deserve this and I it's like a
different Kurt Warner than I'm used to
I'm still thinking of Iowa Kurt Warner
with his wife with the spiky hair like
that's what I'm thinking I know well
what did you think when you heard that I
just did you think Curtin you thought
you could play I think I should well I I
just want to throw the challenge flag on
all of it I just think he's really kind
of placating to his ego a little like he
did with his April Fool's joke from a
few years ago where was that Oh said he
would talk to a team was thinking about
coming back to play dirt read it look it
up he said it like three years ago went
on for three days to say no it was real
write em was asked on April 4th and he
said no actually was an April Fool's
joke because he was scared the NFL
Network was reporting it and he started
to realize damn they're gonna want a
source here soon and I don't have anyone
that actually wanted me to come play cuz
i bullshitted it just to make me feel
good with my ego or fool everybody else
out there I forgot he revealed an April
Fool's joke
three days later he went on with it he
sent it on Twitter right and then he
went on the NFL Network reported on it
saying no he is with contacted by teams
I don't like her owner I'm just gonna
put it up well you stay clear this is my
lane I just he's the opposite of what we
were saying before yeah people that that
are afraid of the public and don't speak
truth to the public are my least
favorite people yeah it's it is it's
you're right it's a little bit of just
that politician smile at times I think
ultimately whether I like that was where
I was gonna go to me he will go down
definitely is one of the most overrated
quarterbacks ever I mean ever without a
doubt and I don't mean he was a part of
the great to show out perfect I get that
but the problem is is there's 20 other
quarterbacks that would have won
multiple Super Bowls with that team and
he only won one so I have that's it see
that's where context matters that was
the best team in football for like four
years in a row when we talked five years
in a row in Orlando pages so they had
more compliments about Trent green than
anything well that they of course are
gonna look at that team and go wait we
know we were the talented ones and we
made him I mean think about what
touchdown passed won the Super Bowl for
that remember he threw the past Isaac
Bruce what do we sit there and go what a
pass by no we said damn Isaac Bruce
jumped over the guy caught the ball made
four people
and ran another 40 yards even in the
Patriots a bike
Ricci proles touchdown was catch shimmy
shimmy shake break tackles get into so
that's all I'm saying
I know I sound like a Kurt Warner hater
I will say this though but it does to
come back and do what he did with the
Cardinals later on it's an amazing story
amazing it's yes again but again top
level talent around him Larry Fitzgerald
in his prime Anquan Boldin in his prime
yes with like a guy Steve Breaston who
wasn't bad Hedren James for that we had
Edgerrin James there a little bit yes so
again the story is great and what he
came from is amazing but I feel like
that story like just made him a Hall of
Famer it's like everyone's like well
this is a great story anyone is Super
Ball he's all a Famer and these Kurt
Warner's in the Hall of Fame right Phil
Simms should be in the Hall of Fame
hashtag Phil Simms Hall of Fame let's do
it let's do it let's do it yeah I just
knew you were gonna have something
interesting to say what the April Fool's
thing is the first thing that I went to
my head I was like damn and I didn't the
tweet said at FSU pro day actually had a
team come up and asked if I would
consider doing a private workout haha I
know I'm 43 but intrigued hashtag just
do it and then last thing is I want to
say this he tweeted what last night must
have been a slow news day like he was
mad that people made do you want
attention or not you're maybe the monday
night football host and you don't want
anybody to pay attention to you I don't
know figure it out
but no it's that's why I'm house it
wasn't a slow news day you're a Hall of
Fame quarterback that said team
approached you at 47 that's going to
make news you would be like the oldest
quarterback to ever play that position
that is history thus it's news right
yeah it's funny Phil we should start
that be a fun game to play how much news
can we manufacture with Phil Simms no
that's what I wanted to I know 62 year
old Phil Simms said he has stronger arm
than Kurt Warner had ready to play next
to great headline and I think that we
could get into Phil and like pump him up
to he's like I do think I have a
stronger arm I still bench 450 I bet you
Phil Borat can push more weight than
Kurt Warner Kurt's the Kurt's got some
muscle though he's in the weight room
to be this defiant in front of all right
so here's how we're doing mascot battle
am i judging you today no the citizen
left Co Universe is judging I'm gonna
let you know Sims ahead of time I can't
even remember who I am
I put out the poll and I said who do you
think will win the Knicks mascot battle
right Sims as a giant or left ko as a
jet 61% of people pick Sims here's a
deal I think they were betting because
they were thinking that phil has been
dipping in the family pot and rooting
for his son a little bit more because he
you're still trying to figure out your
argument we're gonna let you go first no
no loser we're gonna put this out I'm
gonna clip this as a video I'm gonna put
it on Twitter and we're gonna let
everyone vote Sims and luf go they get
to pick sims because winner gets ball
doesn't winner get to choose I don't
litter gets to choose winner gets ball
put us on a split screen really quick
Sims you are a giant I am a jet what is
your argument for you in this mascot I
am a giant I am a great mythical figure
okay I am the New York City New York
Football Giants the greatest city in the
world and I am one of the greatest
figures in the world I am a giant you
cannot mess with thyself mythological
right I mmm that's what you're thinking
about a mythological figure no that's
fine because it's funny is when you go
back to Greek mythology the average
height of a giant is 14 feet not that
tall interesting but enough to chop the
wing off of a jet airplane interesting
strong enough to go
Oh mr. jet airplane you can't fly or do
anything now to the people of the
internet I would like to say to you that
do you remember in 1998 dammit yes Jets
were fighting against Godzilla who was
the size of buildings much taller than
14 feet and they destroyed Godzilla a
14-foot giant it's nothing and yes a
giant could clip the wing we saw King
Kong
the wing of a biplane this is a jet we
don't need to get close we hover above
and we drop missiles you can jump and
you can swipe you can't reach us when we
fly over this is a pets in a walk this
is this is this is a private jet for one
these are not they don't have bombs or
guns
woody John have you seen the picture of
the jet I don't see one gun on there I
see propellers fighter jets and giant
has so many different meanings so it's
like it's I what did you just look at
what I go over more I could just you
know of very great size or force
gigantic he's stalling is that in that
fight of the giant whether that be one
one from Game of Thrones I've got a guy
screen I mean that that plane he does
never get off the ground papa he got the
ground he doesn't need to so why do you
have guns nothing was said about guns
and bringing weaponry I can bring
weaponry to then my giant I know what
he's got a big gun - he's gonna shooting
your crap down there's two ways this
thing ends if we're allowed to have
weapons
the Giants done if not kamikaze we're
going right into you and neither of us
are surviving Internet you decide so so
know-it-all serious though what's a
giant like what do you think they're
truly mind after I mean this is one one
I know that's one one and after you
think you could beat one one okay okay
yeah for everybody that's new to the
podcast look at how many arrows which
are our Martin the creator of Game of
Thrones the giant he created in Game of
Thrones was named one one and the reason
he's called one one which giant war the
number 11 one one phil simms
phil simms was George RR Martin's
favorite NFL player and that is why he
named the giant one one I think it's
awesome yeah that's cool he's a zombie
we're still waiting for this next season
probably have to wait like a year and a
half I'm never gonna finish the book and
it's gonna be awful but vote jet or John
I can't like I totally forgot about this
so I know you always do that thanks the
segment that much better can Josh you
are not the ruler and making the
decision but I'm just curious -
seriously what is
Oh giant like what is a giant though
like I said they say it's a mythical
figure are they talking about like this
do you want me then you walked right
into them and you said mythical figure I
was like yes I know but you're not gonna
offer my opinion now I don't want to
sway to public so what about Sims this
thing about saying what is a giant it's
a large yeah I think it's a large yeah I
think of one one that's what I always
thought the gel like George Muresan
standing on Sean Bradley shoulders
exactly that's okay you know 14 feet it
also says it can be a star of relatively
great size and luminosity that's a shine
Airy stars just says giant other
meanings under giant it's basically
telling you it's this force that's so
great that certainly a jet can't
overcome it dictionary.com you're saying
that it's just an adjective it's just so
it could have been the Philadelphia
awesome it's like New York Giants it's
like god this is just a mythical being
out there that controls all I'm trying
to look at pictures of the Jets now I
will say oh but see there's different
logos here like the one in 1960 looks
like a fighter pilot I'm seeing that's
just the way planes looked in 1960 but
now I'm seeing the other ones that just
looks like a plane yeah you don't have
guns there's never been guns coming out
of the Jets okay they're talking about
the New York Jets because there's a lot
of that's the one I think that's the one
I think of - looks like a 737 Boeing
you're in trouble you know bombs you can
carry in a 737 Boeing and just drop them
from above all right guys thank you so
much we're gonna be back on Monday
well this is it this is it are you
kidding me do anything else you want to
go off your chest weed first of all oh
one second we do I think like we're at
the time of the year like we got to give
NBA basketball a little love right no
yes okay I'm working on getting Cameron
back he's playing hardball
is he playing arvo no not really he just
he wants to come in okay I hope he does
- I'd like to have that talk are you so
hot we're gonna do a little bit of MEA
what did you what do you need to get
mazing LeBron us yeah pretty much
will you be a tight end in the NFL
that's like every conversation it's
actually somebody asked me that today
but III just am amazed a LeBron stones
the LeBron of the NFL I guess like who's
the guy that's just like uh tur
dominance longer than you
ever thought was possible I was gonna go
say Quan Berkeley but he Larry Allen
well I mean if you went for looks uh
terminus for a long period of time I got
to go like Tom Brady right I mean just
for the pure length of that from someone
that seems like ports at the highest
level yeah you're still amazed by LeBron
I'm amazed by LeBron from this sense
that's why I just wanted to talk about
it for two seconds
I've never seen a guy who's more
expected to go forty twelve and ten on a
daily basis and he does it and then we
all just go man forty twelve and ten
it's so unbelievable and I grew up in
the Michael Jordan era and I'm still
gonna sit here and tell you Michael
Jordan's better but man is it close yes
I am but it's really close and I mean I
got to really see and be a part of the
Michael Jordan era and and was in high
school and he was going to Championships
and all that still you were more in the
prime than I yeah I just and and I just
still I look at LeBron and just go
listen I know he's not in the West and
he's in the East and people like use
that against him too and I want to be
like well maybe all those players that
are free agencies they never come to the
east cuz they don't want to deal with
LeBron so don't give us a cause to that
effect exactly exactly
but I just am amazed by that I'm I'm
almost rooting against them because it's
gonna be a blowout if he gets to the fun
on this team this is gonna be more
arguments to win the championship I
can't name the other four guys that
started the team with them yeah except
for us see I don't know I said for me I
think for me I'm just amazed the finals
this year will be warriors rock that's
the fight is no doubt but in terms of
LeBron this is the year where if he
makes it
yeah it'll be like a no-lose situation
yeah I hope suppose to what is this is
eighth or nine to be eight in a row
ninth overall Ethan a row finals which
is is really insane no it's insane it's
insane yes
and then if he plays the Warriors no
one's giving him a chance
I hope he'll still do the 40 12 and 10
and his final statistics will get raised
by it he might have a chance if they
play the Rockets I don't think it's high
but I think the style of the Rockets
play if the shots aren't falling yeah
right
and I think he might have a China he's a
better chanting of the rocket the
Rockets have never been there nothing
right is James Chris Paul is getting to
his first championship series okay yeah
Harden's never been like they never
Mendel's pressure yeah they're like
remember what Hardin was like last year
in the game seven he completely folded
the finals with LeBron on the other side
you don't know the mental makeup of that
team you're right the Warriors get there
it's over it might be a four-game sweep
and and we just go wow we're witnessing
one of the greatest like terrors we've
ever seen the Warriors are unstoppable
yeah I also don't agree with you I know
you think it's bad for the NBA it's kind
of cool to be in an era of watching an
unstoppable force I know that we want it
to be crazy but just like you watch
LeBron and go 40 12 and 10 we take this
for granted don't take the Warriors for
Graham I don't take it for granted but I
don't have a challenge myself every game
to be like this ball movement is insane
the talent on the field the court is
insane like I I get like you I go I go
this could be a blowout but then I try
to appreciate the I get it because it's
special it is there's I don't want to on
they're gonna be in the conversation
from one of the greatest teams in the
history of the sport everyone all right
if they didn't lose that one to LeBron
on them we'd be going oh my gosh this is
the greatest run ever they're gonna win
it all I don't think there's any
stopping him yeah I think the thing that
bothers me is this just with that
conversation and then we'll get done
with the podcast it's like I mean
they're just they're top floor players
any one of them would be the second-best
player for the Cavs
that's agree that's really the point
right I mean yeah I mean okay maybe
Thompson for love is close but I still
think I'd take clay Thompson over Kevin
Love because of what he can do
defensively yes gonna shoot better - I
love clay - so you just look at it from
that standpoint and go yeah none of them
are better than LeBron yes
none of them are better than LeBron but
Durant's the only one where it becomes
an argument because Durant could be the
isolated guy on a team yeah I still put
up those numbers he is Durant I think
has made a horrible career decision by
going there though still I actually
think it's it's getting worse because
he's gone he's in he's in a rut metric
he's just in a relevant land to me I
don't even I don't think people even
think about oh yeah that's right he's on
their team they're great it big win
without him it doesn't matter
he's not doesn't play they go 18 to know
without him doesn't matter he missed the
last 18 games last season I'm okay from
a human perspective I would much rather
live in California than Oklahoma City I
would I'm still getting a max contract
yeah he has set up because he lives in
Oakland tons of future ventures in
Silicon Valley because of his fame there
so technically in terms of like
extending his career he's built his post
career life because he's playing on that
day I get all that I know I'm just
saying I don't think he's ever gonna get
the credit for the player that he
probably is because of this I think when
it's all said and done it's like those
Celtics teams in the 70s where you're
like well the whole team was one guy
he's gonna get lost in translation there
I just I just think that's just the
thought I'm surprised you didn't take it
the direction of all the extra miles
LeBron has had to put on his body by
playing two extra months than everybody
for the past nine years plus the
Olympics and and they still forming at
people that's it's beyond amazing
someone out there today oh he's on
steroids what are you like I just can't
take that talk anymore I'm so just
taking care of his body I mean first of
all I you saw him in person does he look
like a guy on steroids now I can promise
you I can lift weights in every other
direction stronger than LeBron James
he's skinny when you see him in person
he's completely changed his body he's
been working out like a Navy SEAL it's
all about balance and course yeah that's
right and to me I think what's troubling
is with the whole LeBron conversation
and guys thank you for sticking with us
and I'm enjoying this I like talking
about basket I watch all um Sixers are
about to steal one in Boston tonight the
Philly for games Tulsa but with LeBron
his two biggest slights in my opinion
were early on the guy can't shoot yeah
and oh he gets tired and big games the
cramps and all that Stein he's learned
how to shoot and his shooting is deadly
and now he's in the best shape of his
career in the teens of his career like
year 13 or 14 and he plays the entire
frickin game yeah so like all of the
knocks about him he fixed and we don't
give him credit for fixing those not
really no it's it's like you said does
it start it's expected which is it's
it's such a rare weird thing - yeah yeah
I mean we really do we don't even make a
big deal but that we say the same thing
with the NFL with the Patriots yes you
guys
everybody gets tired of the Patriots and
they get annoyed and we say appreciate
greatness yeah like what you're seeing
at a Brady and Belichick this is so
uncommon and you need to cherish this
because if not you're gonna go through
your whole life and be like I just took
LeBron for granted yeah took the
Patriots for granted right and we get so
obsessed with the team that sucked last
year that suddenly became good like the
Raptors or do they have a chance and
it's like no like why don't we
appreciate the great beetle I don't know
all right that seems a love Co we'll be
back obviously guys the NFL draft
party's heating up the more you you keep
messaging us about it the more we love
it cuz it's hilarious because it's going
to be a blast but also get in the iTunes
comments leave a five-star review we're
nearing a thousand which is pretty
awesome
whoa whoa big offseason and then also
hit us up on all social media platforms
we are at Sims in left Co Instagram
Twitter we're getting close to a lot of
cool milestones there which is fun for
Sims peace out homies for fender and
good evening everybody and for the lef
koe man
we will holler at you guys later if
you're on it-- if you're on youtube
subscribe share all that good stuff love
you talk to you soon